I noticed itching and a rash. Maybe even mild hives. It ended just below the top of both of my
shoulders, spreading a little bit to top of shoulder, front side, as well as top and behind my right knee.
It inches and I scratch until there are multiple little scabs, same scam pattern at all locations.
This is new in the last few weeks. What if it's the live system detoxing maybe from the SCFT now
using a couple of months or some other pro aspect of the protocol? That's always a possibility
that you are detoxing. Certainly the top of the shoulders, upper, trapezius,
even down into the upper round void muscles can be referred pain, referred rash from the gallbladder.
Bilaterally gallbladder refers to the shoulder area, so it's possible. I mean I would consider doing
with like castor oil packs over the liver or just hot pads over the liver just to
you know, because you'll hit the gallbladder then too, just to make sure that that's not it.
Does it really fit with the right knee though? So I don't know if that is the issue or not.
Certainly it's really easy when your your body chemistry is constantly changing.
And we look at, you know, just switching up your deodorant or not deodorant, but detergent
because where your clothes rub that can be an issue if you're sweating at all with the change
and weather and stuff that can be an issue too. You've been developed a little hypersensitivity
for a short period of time to something that you haven't been hypersensitivity for a long time.
Certainly supporting the detox pathways is the best way to go though. So I think you're we
are on the right track there, but do investigate other possible sensitivities. It still fits to
detoxification pathways still too, but investigate some of those other things as well.